hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the key features of Hegel's
treatment of self-consciousness in that
section of his phenomenology of spirit
the part that's leading up to the
master-slave dialectic is that you can't
have a self-consciousness that is
entirely what it is in complete
isolation from all other
self-consciousness and he's not talking
about some Robin Hood Caruso you know
where it's physically isolated although
we we find out if you have to read the
book that that's not actually the case
rather it you might say that that the
the other self-consciousness who plays
an important role and who mediates
self-consciousness with
self-consciousness of the person is
always involved in the background in
some way so if we use Robin Hood Caruso
he did not exist apart from a world from
which he was able to recover all sorts
of artifacts and able to think about
himself in relation to other people of
people who were absent Hegel in in this
part of the self consciousness section
is not necessarily trying to tell us
universal truths that we can apply to
every single person he's sketching out a
a particular dynamic but we can expand
it further as some people have indeed
done with this section so here we can
talk about the mediation of self
consciousness by its other and its other
is another self consciousness now what
do we mean by mediation hey this is a
very important i galleon term whenever
we talk about something being mediated
we mean that it's part of the process it
is determining or conditioning things
you can't simply remove it or abstract
it out of the the process altogether and
get things in isolation and have them be
entirely what they are here he's going
to talk about a middle term and that's
that's connected with this notion of
mediation and he tells us that
self-consciousness itself is a middle
term which then splits up into
it's two extremes here he's looking at
things in a dyadic way but we could
expand this beyond this so we have one
self-consciousness as the extreme over
here we have the other
self-consciousness as the extreme over
here and he tells us that the middle
term is self-consciousness each extreme
is this exchanging of its own
determinate 'no solute transition into
the opposite that's some very abstract
what is he actually talking about their
each self-consciousness in doing the
work of trying to figure out what it
actually is and to attain certainty and
truth of itself finds out that there's
more to the story that when it digs into
itself it finds out that it is actually
related to this other self-consciousness
or other self consciousnesses and it is
not what it thought that it was and it's
also discovering in the process that the
other person is doing the same thing
that this is what part of what we share
in common as human beings as self
conscious beings in relation to each
other this mirroring that we've talked
about in in another place so he goes on
and he says as consciousness it does
indeed come out of itself yet though out
of itself it is at the same time kept
back within itself it is for itself this
is another key Hegelian term it is being
for itself it is conscious of itself and
this we can say of both
self-consciousness is now here is where
it begins to get more complicated what
about the other self-consciousness the
other self-consciousness is for this
consciousness this consciousness is
aware of has knowledge of grasps we
could say this other self-consciousness
over here and the same thing can be said
in return because remember there is a
reciprocity here a kind of mirroring so
Hegel goes on and he says it is aware
that at once it is and is not another
consciousness and equally that this
is for itself only when it supersedes
itself as being for itself and is for
itself only in the being for self of the
other so if we want to you know
generalize from this as indeed many
commentators have to understand one's
own relation to self to be certain of it
means to some degree taking into account
the other and the way that the other
sees one the way that the other
construes one this is not you know where
the other has you might say holds all
the cards because the same thing is
happening over here the other exists in
relation to me
as self consciousness and is mediated by
me so he goal is going to say here a
very interesting thing
each is for its each is for the other
the middle term each is self
consciousness you might say with a
capital S and capital C for the other
person each it allows the individual to
be related to himself so he says it is
the middle term through which each
mediates itself with itself and unites
with itself and each is for its often
for the other and immediate being on its
own account which at the same time is
such only through this mediation so
self-consciousness is very complex Hegel
towards the end of paragraph 184 and in
185 is now going to bring up another key
Hegelian term that of recognition or
acknowledgement is sometimes how its
translated in its nominal form we in
German this is honor Kenan - literally -
to know another person or to extend
knowing to another person here it's in a
verbal form and Hegel will talk what
we're translating here about a mutual
recognition the German for this is
Gaon's I think on air cannon each is
recognizing if
very rich phrase each is recognizing
itself but also the other the the
opposed the self who is on the other
side right and so this is a very
important dynamic and complex at this
stage of the Hegelian dialectic it's not
something that can be sustained as such
but this is part of what Hegel is moving
towards in the entire process of the
dialectic
you